campé devant ce ch et celle des robert
marchand attend des nouvelles de son
père paul 82 ans souffre d'alzheimer et
il a contracté la coved 19 les médecins
l'ont annoncé à son fils il ya deux
jours un choc et depuis silence radio
donc je suis dans l'inquiétude la plus
totale à ce qui est vraiment malade est
ce que c'est des symptômes légers j'en
aucune dé son père habitait jusqu'à tout
récemment on ch et celle des notre dame
de la merci d'un au nord de montréal ou
au moins sept personnes sont mortes et
24 ont été infectées il y a deux
semaines il a été transféré dans cet
établissement de heureusement est-ce que
c'est dans le transport qui a été
contaminée est ce que ce site si j'ai
aucune des j'accuse personne mais j'ai
des questions du jeu de réponse le ch
est celle des répond qu'il aura des
nouvelles bientôt
mais cette inquiétude est partagée par
plusieurs familles le coronavirus s'est
invitée dans plus de 500 foyers pour
aînés au québec dont la résidence
eva de lavaltrie où 39 personnes ont été
infectées
le manoir du havre à marjah qui compte
25 cas confirmés ou par exemple le ch et
celle des la flèche à shawinigan où 28
résidents sont touchés comment en est on
arrivé là
des syndicats dénoncent le manque de
matériel de protection
je vous donne un exemple les masques de
procédure pour les travailleurs services
alimentaires c'est ici pour cette
période avoir accès
as équipements leur jeu ils croient
qu'il pourrait des grands vecteurs qui
prépare la nourriture de grands défis
actuellement ce sont les résidences pour
personnes âgées des chcd c'est clair et
il faut à ce moment ci davantage
réorganiser le travail
québec veut réorganiser le travail
limité les allées et venues pour réduire
le risque que le personnel des résidents
soit infecté on offre aussi aux
personnels qui est capable de faire
d'aller habiter à l'hôtel payés par le
gouvernement
le gouvernement promet également de
bonifier le salaire des préposés il
décourage par ailleurs les familles
d'aller chercher leurs proches dans des
résidences mais certains comme robert ne
demande qu'un appel vidéo même si est
intubé sur son lit de mort je le vois ça
va m'aider
un au revoir qui espérons le n'est pas
pour bientôt ici sébastien desrosiers
radio canada montréal